so you watching a trailer right wanna
know what the movies about well allow me
to explain
the names filin and i'm an assassin yeah
yeah I know
you've already seen all the assassin
movies and all their sequels right
you seem pretty unscathed that prozis I
see everyone's got a gimmick
Carnot's cliff he's a butcher
specializes in severed heads and chops
off limbs making mac ex-special forces
turbocharged soldiers of fortune
Jane the Ripper she's the honey trap
killer machine
and poison fate wakin were that way of
his self Gaia and as for me what I make
em look like accidents everyday ordinary
accidents but now God problem you see
the love of my life just turned up in a
box Six Feet Under and I'm certain that
it was one of my crew that poor there
she was picking but which one of these
wankers did it I'm gonna find out and
when I do there'll be a few more fatal
accidents around the corner you gotta
set balls you don't you
[Music]
it's going on water that hit letting a
content
lay back down fellas bloody hell don't
make this thought I can accident
[Music]
you